I want to address a very serious
question which is kind of a crazy
question to have to ask about the
President of the United States is Donald
Trump a puppet or merely clueless a
puppet or merely clueless and here's
what I'm referring to
yesterday we learned that Donald Trump
was angry about not being briefed about
that executive order he signed which
appointed a right wing propagandist
Steve Bannon to the National Security
Council this was maybe a new chapter in
our exploration of Trump's reading
abilities as well the two stories sort
of tied together but we basically have
two scenarios will call them scenario a
and scenario B it's possible that a
Donald Trump did read the executive
order but didn't understand it this
proves not only his incompetence as a
president it maybe suggests that his
advisors are sneaking in language to
these documents to empower themselves or
it might just be a follow-up to our
story about Donald Trump's limited
literacy which is that he read it he
just has such a hard time understanding
what he reads that he didn't ultimately
get the message understand what it was
that he was signing option B is arguably
even more treacherous which is that
Donald Trump isn't reading these
disastrous executive orders that he's
signing I I don't know which would be
worse it strikes me that not reading
what he signs is worse than reading and
not understanding it because if he's
reading it I guess he's at least
punitive ly making an effort I don't
know I mean I don't know how long these
executive orders and bills are if
they're so long to the point where you
know it's a thousand pages something
like the Affordable Care Act I see you
getting a bridged version but you should
probably know what you're signing if
it's going to become law what if this is
an order that involved attacking another
country right I mean what other orders
has Donald Trump maybe signed that he
either didn't read or read and didn't
understand and I saw a comment on reddit
quote someone should slip a resignation
letter on Trump's desk with the words
executive order at the top just put the
resignation section on the second page
and the guy might sign it and have
absolutely no idea what's going on
yesterday press secretary Sean Spicer
sort of denied that Trump hadn't been
we've done the executive order in a very
vague and general way he didn't give any
information that disprove the claim like
oh here's who told Trump what it was
that he was signing on to by taking up
the the chairman of the Joint Chiefs of
Staff and the DNI Director of National
Intelligence off of permanent membership
in that committee and putting Steve
Bannon on it here's Sean Spicer not
really answering and then just talking
about how Air Force would be landing
soon thank you yes we'll be landing soon
folks make sure your tray tables are up
seats in the fully upright position
questions about Trump signing stuff he
doesn't know about oh no no look at
something else hey is that the Grand
Canyon outside the window Pat the mere
reality that this is a conversation the
press secretary I would just think about
we want we fight against the
normalization of the insanity that is
the Trump administration it's inevitable
that there's some normalization because
the press secretary is being asked hey
is the president reading and or
understanding or aware of the executive
orders that he's signing and then the
press secretary says yes the president
is aware of the things that he's signing
into law via executive order the mere
conversation that is taking place is an
indication of how nutty things have
gotten and I really hope that Trump
learns this lesson now because as
president you have so many different
people in your ear and they may have
ulterior motives that you have to be
able to sift through everyone's argument
and pick the best one and yes
read the executive orders when they come
across your desk I'd love to hear from
at rumpus about this I mean how do you
defend this do you say well even if
Trump's not reading it the people around
him are just the best and I'm not
worried about it or do you say no I
prefer the country to be run by a
president who doesn't actually read or
under
Stan what it is that he's signing I
genuinely don't know how the committed
Trump Ascan defend this stuff other than
saying it's all fake news right that
that's becoming the only respite that
these trumpets can have because there's
really no explaining away these issues
unless you just deny their existence
altogether yeah I have to keep your
question rhetorical because there's no
way I could possibly answer that discuss
this with us on reddit as many of our
viewers are heading towards 2500 audio
and video audience members on our reddit
discussion forum david pakman.com slash
reddit our e d di t talk about this or
any other stories that are on today's
program Gamefly is sort of like netflix
for video games they have over 8,000 new
and classic games for xbox one Xbox 360
ps4 ps3 Wii and a bunch of other
platforms and you can play as many games
as you want for one monthly fee and if
you find some games you want to keep you
can buy them for a low used price
there's never any due dates or late fees
and our audience can get a free 30-day
trial at Gamefly offer.com slash TDP s
the games are shipped directly to you
with return envelopes included there's
no contracts and you can rent games
through the mobile app get the free
30-day trial for the David Pakman show
audience and support our show by going
to Gamefly offer.com slash TDP s